here's the thing about all my music i i
am
so i'm a hopeless romantic i love
i love the idea of being in love and
i've always felt that way and i learned
to feel from the movies i learned to
feel from
good books and literature growing up and
poems and
shakespeare and there was something
really like um
haunting and romantic about writing love
songs
and uh so a lot of any kind of
music that has been you know aggregated
into my life
from the outside world it comes through
me in like a really
like very syrupy it's like spoon feeding
ice cream too much like i i love
music but i feel like i've with i've
like held back a lot of music from
releasing it because i feel like
sometimes it's a bit too much like it's
a bit like
lame but well you say lame but like if
it's coming from the heart they always
say whatever you're doing if you have
feeling and you mean it
that's when it's the best right whether
it's acting or whether it's music so
if it's coming out in your music maybe
you shouldn't hold back and you should
just let it go and go this is what i'm
feeling this is what i'm writing and
people either gravitate towards it or
they won't so
yeah yeah yeah i mean and growing up i
had like interesting
i had an interesting relationship with
music my parents you know they
they introduced me to you know music
like
bob dylan and the grateful dead and van
morrison
and the doors very very controversial
music for a very young person especially
bob dylan which i took to and i just was
obsessed with bob dylan
growing i was very young i'm still
obsessed
with him to this day but um
his music was so interesting to me
because i mean he
absolutely jumpstarted this the era of
folk um you know protester
music and at a time when
people's voices needed to be heard he he
was creating these
beautiful lyrical structure almost like
a rap
now would be a rap battle he was doing
that and it to me it was just
it was unlike anything i'd ever heard
and anything i've ever heard up until
now
he was you know putting his heart on his
sleeve and
you know millions of other people's
hearts on there on his sleeve what are
you saying so
that elliott smith yeah really with him
growing up
magic tragic but just made the music
just so much
deeper and oh man even now you want to
have a sunny day and ruin it
elliott smith elliot smith you know go
back to your childhood you said there
was
it was a little chaotic it was dramatic
it was all these things
do you think did it did it was it in a
good way
or was it both in a good way in a bad
way did it create some anxiety did you
did you feel stressed were there did you
have that teenage angst
you know the teen man my first book was
all my teenage angst
all of it lifelong beauty was all
written
uh i was i was i was like i was teen
angst
for most of my life until i hit i think
like 25 and then i was like oh man i
gotta
i gotta like figure this out um but
yeah i growing up i mean i feel i feel
like
everybody has the same
story in a different way and my
angst growing up lent itself to now
finding the peace to know that it was
okay to feel
down and sad sometimes and it's okay to
feel down and sad
even now but to to not linger
to not linger too far into those
feelings and understand that they're
just
thoughts and feelings and you can be a
passenger to those
moments and then like because nothing
here's the other thing michael like
nothing really
matters everything is temporary and
that's
the greatest awakening that i had was
in my like 20 my late 20s
i was like oh wow like nothing
is forever like everything's temporary
so like to live in the moment
and be present in yourself it helps